Dave, I heard you say in an interview,
this was an emotional journey for you, this movie.
And then thought, it's Lego Ninjago,
but I wanna believe you on this.
It's true, it's true.
The first time Justin and I got in the recording booth
we were doing this very intimate father-son scene
and I found myself crying.
(clearing throat)
Excuse me.
Good timing for a voice crack,
I'm still livin' through it.
Crying uncontrollably.
Yeah.
And kind of like crying harder than I do
in a movie where I play a recovering heroin addict.
[Conan] Yeah.
(audience laughing)
Then we finished the scene and I kinda
took a step back and evaluated the room
and it was some interesting energy
and I realized I was playing a green ninja
Lego piece and I needed to reel it in a bit, yeah.
(laughing)